full storms are battering Northern
California for a third day in a row the
heavy rain is making creeks and rivers
swell an already soaked region storms
triggered mudslides in Santa Cruz at
south of San Francisco and that area
could see up to 8 inches of rain before
the storm moves away later today eight
more inches John Blackstone is in Morgan
Hill where an overflowing reservoir is
causing concern for people downstream
John good morning good morning well
water running out of the Anderson
reservoir continues to create a torrent
here in fact nine of California's 12
major reservoirs are now above their
water tote water averages for this time
of year those are the highest totals
since 2011 the threat of flooding
continues across Northern California the
water rushing out of the overflow in the
Anderson reservoir is swelling creeks in
its path while those living downstream
wait and worry
if the Creek word overflow the flood
pattern is just gonna come right through
this this whole neighborhood it's not
the only reservoir filled to capacity by
recent rains for the first time in 20
years
officials Monday were forced to open the
spillway at the Don Pedro reservoir
about two hours south of Sacramento last
time that happened it contributed to the
flooding in areas in and around the town
of Modesto we're gonna keep the spillway
open for four days we're going to
release enough water so that we can
accommodate the storms that are coming
in in Oroville engineers say that dam
spillway is stable and able to handle
the rain occasionally you see some
erosion here and there but nothing
that's of concern at this time nearly
two hundred thousand residents who live
below it are still under an evacuation
warning told to be prepared to leave if
necessary meanwhile hundreds were forced
to evacuate quickly in San Joaquin
County south of Sacramento late Monday
officials say they were able to halt a
developing breach in a levee that could
have impacted dozens of rural homes the
rain is also creating headaches in the
Santa Cruz Mountains two hours south of
San Francisco where mudslides have
blocked roads and toppled trees
when this giant fir tree fell near Santa
Cruz commuters with chainsaws helped to
clear the road before firefighters
arrived the county's Public Works
superintendent says this winter season
has been relentless we're tired our
crews have one day a week off if they're
lucky since California's rainy season
began in October San Francisco has
logged more than 24 inches of rain
that's already above the city's normal
annual rainfall total Nora all right
John thank you so much